Fox News is in somewhat of a panic in
the wake of the Wisconsin Supreme Court
election results that once again
highlighted the strength and passion
behind abortion rights democracy and
other crucial issues and how the
Republican stance on those
things the actions they've been taking
is just not popular especially as will
be talked about here the younger
Generations get more active in politics
and there's different approaches I'll
show you a couple here some just
recognizing how these issues directly
have impacted election results and I've
seen kind of here and there calls for
Republicans to moderate themselves
otherwise they're going to keep losing
but some do what I'm about to show you
here with kellyanne Conway what she's
doing which is come up with a rather
incoherent and cope copy way to deal
with the fact that
the modern conservative ideology just
isn't popular with the majority of
Americans and that's why we saw the
underwhelming midterm results that's why
we saw and especially because the
Republican party is being driven by this
Maga ideology and the radical stances on
things like abortion rights that's why
we've seen when abortion rights
are on the ballot or when they're
directly tied to a candidate abortion
rights Prevail
um as I said that we Wisconsin Wisconsin
election results and others and this is
how kellyanne Conway uh synthesized this
reality so we can't be beaten on this
policy wise I think we've already won
the policy arguments on the economy on
education on a number of issues I think
we've got some work to do on the young
people who think differently on abortion
perhaps or guns or climate change but
even there the Democrats messages are
usually cynical the place I'm really
concerned the thing I'm really concerned
about so cynical let's protect women's
rights with this Laura is that the left
becomes a turnout machine with young
people because influencers have this
domino effect lemming-like effect of
people just all them wanting to be part
of the same crowd and if they succeed in
that way we're not doing a great job
competing for ballots we're just
competing for votes our candidates lost
the early voting
miserably last time I mean someone like
Dr Oz lost the early vote to John
Federman by over four to one so we need
to compete for ballots not just voters
and not just minds and I think they're
trying to do that with these influencers
I have faith in the American people I
think I'll catch on to this and say I
want a policy argument
well kellyanne I think you raised an
excellent point though and and it seems
like the Republicans are always playing
catch-up even though it's obvious what
happened last time with the early voting
and you know all these folks who run the
RNC and other you know other I guess
Republican Outlets that are supposed to
be getting this right this time what are
they doing are they you know getting
their own ballot harvesting operation
going where it's illegal are they you
know lining up their own channels for
early voting is that going to happen
this time do you have confidence in that
so they're trying to make this absurd
distinction between uh and we'll get to
another clip here from Fox but
between
ballots and votes and they're saying
Democrats go and they harvest ballots
and they win through the ballot game and
we were just focusing on votes and
nuanced policy discussions
um I haven't seen policy coming
significant nuanced uh meaningful policy
conversations coming from Republicans at
least the driving Corps of the
Republican Party being Maga in a very
long time maybe ever when it comes to
that particular movement but
there's this perception that the
increased votes or the success in
different elections and this is slightly
different than this it's different than
the stolen election
conspiracy theory but it kind of is a
child of that where there's something
malicious a mysterious going on with the
Democratic party and that's why more
young voters are supporting them or
that's why they were successful in these
states
um in this election or that election or
that's why abortion rights are impacting
elections so significantly that's why
people care about democracy all that and
it's just not true it's not a balanced
response are the ways the way that we
vote and uh more people just vote in
favor of some of these Democratic
policies in a lot of situations
especially younger voters but even they
try to craft this narrative
um
that
it's just the Gen Z that Republicans are
unpopular with which they are very
unpopular with Gen Z but the radical
stances on abortion gun control
democracy with the attempts to overturn
the election results
um and others are unpopular with the
majority of
just America generally and still gen Z
is a very small portion of the voting
population so it's mostly not gen Z and
still you're very unpopular
um and find ways to eke out victories of
course and still have a lot of power but
generally the ideology is just not
something people can get behind and it's
not going to consistently be supported
especially as
I said the younger Generations get more
involved in politics and so for
kellyanne Conway it's let's ballot
Harvest you can only be successful in
ballot harvesting which is just getting
a third party to take someone's ballot
to the polling place so if it's an
elderly person they can
have a family member or something take
that ballot to the polling place for
them
um
but it's only successful if you actually
have people to fill out the ballot who
are real voters who actually want to
support the Republican party and that's
your issue
for sure next moment here responding to
these results check that out Brett you
followed these results in Wisconsin
um
interesting here's what we found for the
Gen Z vote into 2020 midterms they won
77-21 for Democrats and now there's this
you know this it's not a five alarm fire
but it's concern among Republicans as to
how they get young people to vote for
them especially with the issue of
abortion uh more or less on the ballots
in so many different state races uh this
is what kellyanne Conway told you it's
just last hour here and there's more
kellyanne Conway but I have an idea it's
gonna be it's gonna sound a little goofy
a little strange
and I'm not normally giving strategic
advice to Republicans but I'm going to
do it here you can take it to leave it
my wild idea
for not alienating certain voting
populations on the issue of abortion
is to have a less radical view on
abortion that would be my advice to the
Republican Party
um but definitely interesting to see
different ways in which he's being more
authentic and recognizing just the
Republicans have a stance that isn't
popular among so many populations while
Kelly and Conway saying it's a ballot
versus votes game
and
um we will continue to watch it all
move forward make sure you're subscribed
to me on YouTube at Luke Beasley